we search for the coolest places in l.a
to play ping pong with the portable
pongfinity net that can turn almost
anything to an epic ping pong setup
the first point is santa monica beach
the margins are pretty slim
[Music]
is that allowed of course it is next
location
many speech skateboards
looking for our next spot
okay we're waiting for our quesadillas
so let's play you guys are telling me
where online online yeah we actually
have a special campaign for the net on
our web store so go and get yourself one
of these bad boys it's pretty convenient
[Music]
oh
did you see that
looks like a nice spot
i'll get the point for that nice rally
uh
[Music]
so this is pretty challenging
i think so
yes i got it thank you thank you okay
guys this is the bigger version of the
pongfinity net not yet on sale but maybe
one day
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
done
[Music]
sorry
a lot of lucky points there
[Music]
oh risky
no i'm so confused by this place
okay i thought i'm i'm not really sure
about this one but let's try
ping pong in front of the traditional
school buses
yeah yeah there is longfinity those four
[Music]
okay okay okay
this is a cool spot for this one we need
to get
high out to no pressure but whoever hits
the ball down has to go get it
foreign
this is so risky we don't want to lose
the ball
[Music]
oh this is intense i don't want to lose
this
[Applause]
we didn't lose the ball so i'm pretty
happy
[Music]
oh okay
this is a long one no yes come on
you know where to get yours from the
until next time for every net sold this
month we'll throw in a free pack of
spontaneity balls